In 2017 North Korea went on a missile launch bonanza
first into the Sea of Japan in February, then its first ever intercontinental ballistic missile
on July 4th, Happy Birthday America, and 18 other missile tests
plus a cyberattack on 150 countries
disrupting everything from banks to hospitals
No five nine
But pretty effective according to North Korean media
Americans on internet websites
Now have nuclear phobia kim jong un's threats of war weren't new
But this time they were echoed by the US on twitter by the way
Which seems like a bad way to reach someone in North Korea
But hey tensions were at an arguably all-time high and then
something changed out of nowhere after the deadline Kim jong-un announced
He would send two athletes to the
2018 Olympics and not just that but with South Korea under a unified flag
his sister and an entourage of suspiciously enthusiastic fans
also traveled to the South. Missile testing suddenly stopped and Kim even met with a US Secretary of State
He also left the country for the first time as supreme leader to visit Xi Jinping in China
And then the biggest news yet both North and South held an inter-korean summit
For Kim hugged the South Korean president even stepped on South Korean soil. I mean that sounds like a story from the onion
It's a complete 180 from non-stop missile launches two friendly smiles and hugs in just five months for many
This is completely bizarre for others
It's the obvious result of successful foreign policy
but what looks like desperation or
Backpedaling or even foolishness is really just the continuation of a long-standing very rational very
Calculated survival strategy with a twist so what exactly is going on and how will it end?
Kim jong-eun has one thing on his wish list
Stay in power for him power means wealth and luxury and safety for his family
So if that's the goal you might wonder why not just you know show out and enjoy those things he appears to do the opposite
Risking everything by poking the biggest guns he could find
That's why so many see him as genuinely crazy and the media of course has no interest in alleviating that word
Worry is their business model
But it's not true Kim inherited a very poor hungry
primitive country if he does nothing the country will wither and fail no one to make Swiss cheese or basketballs and becoming a
Self-sustaining or just not terrible country would mean economic reform reform brings better living conditions for everyone
Which you might expect would protect Kim from revolution?
But it's just the opposite a population that can just barely feed itself only has time to do exactly that
Revolutions are feats of strength not weakness
What's really dangerous is a taste of the good life a peek at what they could have?
Reformed could eventually make the north as successful as its neighbor, but it would mean goodbye for Kent so he needs resources
But can't afford economic reform the solution is the same kind of socialism the country has always dreamed of and never
Delivered shared or resources aka four and eight, and how do you get handouts as a totalitarian country with death camps?
But intimidating a superpower like the United States is hard if they had six hundred billion dollars to rival the US military they
Wouldn't need to scare them anyway
so instead they skip the entire tech tree straight to nuclear weapons a single nuke is the ultimate shield against war and
Uproar which also makes it the perfect
Negotiating tool the thought of denuclearizing North Korea is so attractive the world will do anything for the slightest chance to get it
including forgetting 15 years of failed foreign policy
just two years after Kim jong-un took power a
Former exchange student in Pyongyang and now expert and rail and cop wrote a book called the real
North Korea Co 40 wrote sounds familiar when North Korea are unhappy they follow the same routine they first
manufacture a crisis and drive tensions as high as
Possible when newspaper headlines tell the world that the Korean Peninsula is on the brink of war the North Korean government suggests
Negotiations the offer is accepted with a sigh of relief
Giving North Korean diplomats the leverage to squeeze maximum concessions
It's the North Korean version of the hero's journey the same story told over and over and over again
But because we want to believe we buy it every time at any given moment
Kim is either in total assault mode creating fear and therefore our desperation for negotiation or total charm mode
Convincing the world is a new man
He just needs some financial support man this cycle of aggression charm and repeat is happening now
But it's not new at all there have been six other rounds of negotiations
North Korea agreed to abandon their nuclear program in 2005 they got what they wanted and then broke their promise
But this time is a bit different their nuclear program has been building up for almost 40 years to one goal the ability to reach
The US mainland until then there was no realistic chance of their giving up the program
It's their one and only deterrent the only key to Kim's life lesson learned from Iraq in Libya on November 28th
They tested the whole song 15 proving. They could reach anywhere in America and two months later
They joined the Olympics and turned on the charm that timing is no coincidence they accomplished their goal
No need for more missile testing now
it's time to cash in get all they can from halting the tests while keeping even if it means hiding the ability to target the
U.s.
They couldn't have scheduled it better xi Jinping was probably pressuring them to relax and tensions were extremely high with the u.s.
the administration really wants to show its strategy worked giving Kim enormous negotiating leverage
It's possible the talks will fail or succeed with flying colors
But here's my rough prediction Kim will excite the world with concessions
But most will be completely symbolic cheek smiles and no concrete promises
He'll agree to stop nuclear development, which they no longer need in exchange for some American military concessions that also benefit
China who would prefer America back out of Asia little to nothing will change inside, North Korea
more of the same terrible oppression and real
Reunification won't be possible anytime soon, but American and South Korean politicians will declare a huge success
But so will North Korea who finally got a seat at the table has its security guaranteed plus
Maybe some economic benefits
Exactly as planned when he next finds himself low on cash or in need of something without the attention to get it well
He'll know exactly what works and by the time North Korea makes its next move
You could be well on your way to making yours everything you saw in this video
I made in a graphic design application called affinity designer
It's far cheaper than Adobe Illustrator, but still a bit intimidating for beginners
So a great way to learn it is with a class like this one on Skillshare
It'll walk you through making digital graphics and easy to follow
Bite-sized videos everything from colors to custom shapes brushes and exporting if you want to make videos like this one
This is a great way to get started and with a premium membership you pay one low price for all the classes you want so
You can find the perfect one for you jump around or take multiple at a time
There are classes on photography finance app development and something I'm gonna check out calligraphy something. That's really cool
Is that you can browse other people's projects for inspiration?
I mean look at all the cool lettering people have made who took this calligraphy class and for poly matter viewers the first
500 people to sign up with a link in the description get two free months of unlimited classes
Thanks again to skill share and to everyone who gives it a try
(Engsub by many people)